et nous poursuivons notre soirée
spécialement bourgogne franche comté où
nous vous le disons depuis 20h le front
national arrive en tête de ce premier
tour des élections régionales estimation
ipsos sopra steria nous allons voir les
chiffres pour chacune des dix listes en
compétition en bourgogne et en
franche-comté regardez donc le front
national la liste menée par sophie
montel arrive en tête avec un peu plus
de 30 2% des suffrages de ce premier
tour devant la liste de françois
sauvadet
les républicains udi avec 23% des
suffrages et devant marie-guite dufay
près de 23% 22,8 pour la liste conduite
par le parti socialiste
nous allons voir les résultats vous
voyez là les résultats des parties
suivant si nous continuons la liste il y
a ensuite dans l'ordre près de 5% à 7%
pour maxime thiébaut la liste debout la
france 4,7 pour le front de gauche mené
par nathalie vermorel et vous voyez les
derniers 3 un gilles 4 pour le modem 4 %
pour europe ecologie les verts julien
gonzalez pour l'alliance écologiste
indépendante 2 de 1,4 pour lutte
ouvrière est claire rocher et en
dernière position charles henri gal web
pour l'union populaire républicaine est
avec nous sur ce plateau nos trois
premiers invités qui seront avec nous
pour cette première partie de soirée
je vous rappelle donc le score du front
national qui arrive en tête 30 2,1 pour
cent selon les premières estimations
avec nous françois patriat socialiste
vous êtes président sortant de la région
bourgogne bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
arnaud danjean vous êtes conseiller
régional vous êtes chef de file pour la
liste elle est rude et ici en saône et
loire
on sort merci d'être avec nous edouard
ferrand vous êtes député européen du
front national forcément la première
question elle est pour vous ce score
était attendu pour le front national
en bourgogne franche comté bon sur
madame bonsoir à tous nos téléviseurs je
voudrais simplement vous dire que ce
soit c'est une grande satisfaction mais
nous sommes qu'au premier tour
nous avons aujourd'hui c'est vrai une
dynamique une dynamique est lancée je
remercie d'ailleurs tous les électeurs
qui se sont déplacés parce que c'est
bien qu'en bourgogne et en franche-comté
justement les patriotes se mobilisent on
s'est mobilisé pour le premier tour
il faut aussi se mobiliser pour le
second tour et le second tour c'est dans
une semaine et je crois que nous avons
encore une grosse réserve de voix et le
front national n'a pas encore dit son
dernier mot
cette dynamique étant lancée on l'avait
vu aux élections européennes puisque en
bourgogne ont fait 24 % 26% aux
sélections départementales
aujourd'hui plus de 30% on rassemble un
bourguignon et franc-comtois sur trois
demain j'espère pour les élections
présidentielles un sur deux parce que le
front national dans une dynamique et
cette dynamique et bien c'est
aujourd'hui nous jours la première
partie de cette élection en ayant en
ligne de mire bien évidemment l'élection
présidentielle parce que les français on
voit au besoin vraiment d'un grand
souffle
je crois que c'est un désaveu cinglant
pour la droite et la gauche françois
sauvadet s'écroule complètement la
gauche essaie de résister mais
finalement cette élection montrent qu'
elle ne jouera pas un grand rôle sur le
plan national dans les élections
régionales demain et cette dynamique
elle est favorable au front national
partout dans les régions le front
national arrive dans beaucoup d'endroits
en tête et cette dynamique nous permet
de dire qu'aujourd'hui si nous nous
mobilisons si après ce premier tour et
bien les français ont compris que
maintenant il fallait changer cette
politique de droite et de gauche
eh bien je pense que dimanche soir nous
serons également peut-être une grande
surprise si les bourguignons il faut
quand toi nous suivent arnaud danjean un
certain nombre de sondages ont longtemps
donné françois sauvadet en position pour
remporter cette région la situation est
devenue beaucoup plus serré beaucoup
plus incertaine
qu'est ce qui s'est passé de votre point
de vue dans l'est dans les dernières
semaines deux choses principalement
d'abord il faut pas oublier le contexte
très particulier dans lequel nous sommes
depuis les événements tragiques que nous
avons connue et je pense que quiconque a
fait campagne sur le terrain
je m'excuse parce que je suis le seul
candidat présent sur ce plateau beaucoup
de wade accord
enfin je trouve ça comme un peu incongru
quand on est sur le terrain on a bien
senti qu'il y avait une crainte il y
avait une peur et que ce sentiment a
bénéficié incontestablement au front
national
le deuxième le deuxième facteur qui a
bénéficié à plein au front national au
premier tour est ce que ça sera une
dynamique suffisante au deuxième tour
moi je ne le crois pas et je ne l'espère
pas mais c'est l'exaspération
l'exaspération l'exaspération vis-à-vis
des politiques en général vis-à-vis des
gouvernants général et donc droite et
gauche sont mis dans le même sac
moi vous savez pour une analyse très
objectif du vote front national salon ça
s'est longtemps limité à des questions
sécuritaires et d'immigration
aujourd'hui ce socle reste mais il
s'alimente d'une nouvelle matrice ça
fait longtemps que je le dis parce que
je le constate sur des terrains qui sont
pas naturellement favorable au front
national c'est la matrice façon gauche
et droit tous pareils on tente autre
chose et on vous envoie notre signe
d'exaspération bon bah ça a fonctionné à
plein sur ce premier tour je note
toutefois que ce n'est pas une totale
surprise ça vient d'être appelé le front
national était en tête en bourgogne
franche comté aux européennes il ya un
an et demi le front national était en
tête dans les derniers sondages qui
sortait à peu près avec les même étiage
d'ailleurs il ya quelques jours
donc c'est tout sauf une vraie surprise
encore une fois c'est une dynamique de
premier tour
moi je reste quand même persuadé que sur
une dynamique de deuxième tour
nous avons la possibilité de mobiliser
nous avons un certain nombre de deux
reports possibles nous avons aussi je
crois un tassement possible de ce vote
d'exaspération mais c'est vrai qu'il
faut absolument tenir compte de cet
appel qui est envoyé et qui est
maintenant quelque chose de structurel
voilà ça fait depuis un an et demi deux
ans qu'on a qu'on a ce type ce type de
vote et ce type de premier tour les
européennes ce n'est qu'un tour lie à
deux tours et les deux tours servent
justement à ça est-ce que entre les deux
tours il ya une forme de vote utile qui
ce qui se manifeste par rapport à un
vote de d'exaspération et de
contestation qui a joué à plein au
premier tour françois patriat vous avez
manifester ce que vous pensiez du front
national il ya quelques jours en disant
voter front national c'est voter des ch
vous avez le sentiment de pas avoir été
entendu ce soir donc ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui parce que à cette heure ci
on sait une chose
conformément aux sondages on y à peu
près dans mon métier qui était prévu
avec un front national qu'elle qu'il est
estimée une gauche plus haut qu'elle
n'était prévue et une droite
républicaine plus bas qu'elle n'était
prévu si on veut tirer des conclusions
pour l'issue du scrutin
ce qu'on sait c'est que ça va se jouer à
un ou deux points on regarde les
réserves qu'à la gauche et l'anglais
certaine les réserves car la droite et
on a aussi et la marge cas le fm de
pouvoir progresser parce qu'il a
progressé dans les derniers scrutins
mais tout ça va se jouer à deux points
donc tiré ce soir des conclusions
définitives n'a aucun sens
ensuite la surcroît de nouveaux temps
acquis at il profité
il a profité bien entendu au fn il plus
de votants on veut qu'ils sont allés sur
le fn il a profité aussi à la gauche est
malheureusement en train malheureusement
pour la les républicains il a
aujourd'hui pas profité à eux c'est eux
qui sont les premiers perdants sur les
premiers perdants et chacun doit retirer
ce soir les conclusions
ce qui veut dire qu'avec les sondages
tels qu'ils sont donnés aujourd'hui il
ya encore deux part d'inconnu première
premières pentes inconnu c est ce que le
front de gauche va faire un coupet 5
donc est ce qu'ils seront mobilisés pour
le deuxième tour est ce que cette
destination aux acteurs est ce que
l'europe
europe ecologie les verts vont faire 5
se maintenir aussi sa sas le compte on
aura les résultats définitifs ce qu'on
dit à cette heure ne sera peut-être pas
ce qu'on dira à vaincre en effet pour la
droite ce sujet debout la france à ce
sujet des alentours de la variole b5
ce qui est important tout de même on
voit deux bouts la france il m'apparaît
que ce sont des électeurs qui ne sont
pas séduits par la droite républicaine
classique et qui ne et qui n'ont pas
voulu voter front national
alors qu'elle sera au deuxième tour leur
vote on ne sait pas même sur une
mobilisation supplémentaire
ce que je souhaite c'est que face au
danger que représente le front national
je vais répondre à votre question la
mobilisation soit forte pour les partis
républicains notamment pour le parti
auquel j'appartiens
pour répondre à votre question sur neige
ce que j'ai dit je t'ai pas seul à le
dire
d'autres l'ont dit compris à temps à
attendre christian estrosi ce que je dis
aujourd'hui c'est que à mon avis des
chouettes le chaos
''je souhaite le cas où il souhaite le
carreau dans notre pays et il souhaite
avoir un gouvernement
des gens qui soient radicalement à
droite pour re a dit que pour
radicaliser les populations qui sont
venus d'orient ou d'ailleurs et par là
même à voir dans notre pays une montée
de l'islamisme c'est ce qu'il souhaite
aujourd'hui ils le disent ils l'écrivent
et moi c'est moi c'est ma crainte à moi
je les dis un peu violemment
je les dis aussi autrement dit l'autre
jour j'ai dit que aujourd'hui le
meilleur agent électoral pour le fn
s'était d'ailleurs je répète ici
ce qu'a dit marion maréchal-le pen elle
a dit avec un cynisme inouï
avec un cynisme inouï il est vrai que
les attentats en booster notre campagne
voilà dynamiser notre campagne
donc je retire parce que j'ai dit
c'était certes un peu caricatural je
vous le dis mais ça reflète au fond une
idée que je crois certaines de voir que
les les partis extrémistes
montrons si jamais le front national
arrivé au pouvoir merci françois patriat
recevait discussions avec vous je dors
ferrand juste fois parce que
convaincante sophie montel autres
candidates pour la liste front national
qui arrive en tête avec 32% des voix je
vous le rappelle pour ce premier tour
estimations france télévisions sophie
montel en direct de besançon du qg du
front national
nous vous retrouvons en direct vous avez
entendu françois patriat avez vous
profité à vous bénéficiez du contexte
national finalement ce que vous
récupérez ce contexte à votre faveur
sophie montel
moi ce que je crois c'est que bon nombre
de français ont compris que suite aux
événements du 13 novembre le front
national avait depuis longtemps dénoncé
les problèmes qui arrivaient en france à
savoir le fondamentalisme islamisme
islamistes et les attentats et les
dérives la montée du communautarisme
tout ça le front national dénonce depuis
des années et des années
donc voilà le front national ne profite
de rien si ce n'est d'avoir vu clair
avant tout le monde est contre tous
d'ailleurs puisque que ce soit l'ump et
le gouvernement ump ou le gouvernement
socialiste
ils se sont évertués pendant des années
à diminuer de manière drastique les
effectifs de nos forces de l'ordre
notamment
je rappelle quand même le bilan de
sarkozy c'est 54 mille militaires en
moins à 12500 gendarmes et policiers en
moins
j'entendais monsieur dans gens qui
disaient que le vote front national
était un vote d'exaspération bien
ambitieux denjean vous vous trompez le
vote front national est un vote
d'adhésion
les électeurs les français on renvoyait
dos à dos ce soir l'ump le parti
socialiste ils n'ont plus confiance en
vous ni vos solutions
monsieur denjean voilà donc moi
j'appelle tous les patriotes à se
mobiliser à se rassembler pour le
deuxième tour car nous pouvons le 13
décembre je crois très sincèrement nous
avons énormément de réserves de voix
contrairement à ce qui a été dit chez
les abstentionnistes
chez les républicains chez les électeurs
de debout la france
voilà moi j'appelle tous les patriotes à
se rassembler et à offrir une victoire
au front national pour offrir un vrai
changement à la france et à la bourgogne
franche comté sûr de lilian melet sophie
montel on a remarqué que vos premiers
mots ont été pour parler de la situation
française et internationale pas
franchement régionales est ce que c'est
la campagne que vous allez faire entre
les deux tours c'est en grande partie
celles que vous avez fait d'ailleurs
avant le premier tour aussi
non non là vous vous êtes caricatural
sur monsieur au contraire nous avons
développé des axes de campagne très
régionaux des commandes axes de campagne
de bon sens nous avons parlé décidé
lycée nous avons parlé de la dépense des
dépenses de fonctionnement de leur
explosion de l'explosion de la dette
nous avons mis dos à dos la gestion
sauvadet la jonction du fait qu'ils se
ressemblent d'ailleurs que ce soit en
conseil régional au conseil régional de
franche comté au conseil départemental
de côte-d'or où je le rappelle les
investissements ont chuté
la dette a explosé les impôts pour
exposer donc si vous voulez pour moi
sauvadet du fait
c'est bonnet blanc et blanc bonnet voilà
et ça les électeurs l'ont parfaitement
compris voilà il se trouve que le 13
novembre il ya eu des attentats
perpétrés par des barbares est
effectivement la campagne c'est
nationalisées mais ce n'est pas du fait
du front national et moi j'ai envie de
dire aux électeurs ce soir voyez voter
ump voter ps c'est la dèche pour la
france voilà c'est l'explosion du
chômage et l'explosion de la sécurité
c'est le développement du
communautarisme c'est la ruine de notre
pays c'est la soumission toujours et
encore plus à cette union européenne qui
désindustrialise notre pays et nos
régions donc voilà soyons clairs de
francs seraient soyons frais fier d'être
bourguignon et comtois relevons la tête
et gagnons le 13 décembre c'est par là
c'est pour la france tout ça sophie
montel version direct de besançon
réponse peut-être arnaud danjean
moi je maintiens ce que j'ai dit madame
ont-elles dit ne laissez pas un vote
d'adt d'exaspération c'est un vote
d'adhésion mais d'adhésion à quoi
d'adhésion à des gens qu'on proposait le
même programme en bretagne où le même
programme en bourgogne franche comté
moi je cherche toujours la façade
maritime de la bourgogne franche comté
quand elle nous dit mais sauvadet du
fait c'est la même chose
excusez moi les compétences attendait
les compétences de la région c'est pas
les compétences du département
donc c'est pas c'est pas du tout un vote
d'adhésion à des propositions qui
n'excuse pas sûr de la tête les olé la
région vous avez vous avez vous avez
vous avez bénéficié d'un vote
d'exaspération cet objectif
son objectif c'est de votre fête s'est
lui-même ps
non mais cette engeance quand même je
sais je sais je sais maman tels que vous
adorez les slogans et que vous ne savez
pas faire autre chose que des slogans
vos slogans au marché pour le premier
tour très bien moi j'en prends acte je
ne conteste pas votre victoire de
premier tour il me dit simplement ce
sera très bien pour le deuxième je vous
dis simplement oui pour un deuxième tour
je pense que les électeurs regarderont
aussi d'un petit peu plus près parce que
vous proposez pour la région la région
s'est pas de problème de l'union
européenne c'est pas le problème j'ai
département fait problèmes de la région
c'est le problème de la région bien sûr
que si donc les slogans c
slogan c'est très confortable mais il
souffre poser les choses on va
poursuivre la dette c'est pour vendre
seulement madame ans elle évoque des
slogans mais en plus elle pratique le
mensonge et la contre-vérité les impôts
il n'ya pas d'impôt à la région alors il
faut nous avons il y en a pas y'a pas
représente 5 % des impôts 8% les impôts
paient pas d'impôts deux la dette
madame madame monte elle n'a pas dû
regarder ce que dit capital capital
c'est pas un journal de gauche il dit la
région de bourgogne est la région la
mieux gérée de france avec la dette ces
trois ans et demi c'est trois ans et
demi que c'est pas moi qui l'écrit trois
ans et demi dont explosion de la dette
dit lacourt est bonne la dette la cour
des comptes ne dit pas ne dis pas que
nous sommes endettés pas du tout donc
vous pouvez pas dire des contrevérités
comme ça annoncée des slogans et avouée
aujourd'hui est aujourd'hui que vous
avez fait une campagne sur la sécurité
les régions n'ont aucune compétence sur
la sécurité
vous faites une campagne contre l'europe
les régions n'ont pas de compétence
européenne s'est elle pas sur
l'immigration bien sûr que ça fait mal à
monter elle a commencé sa campagne à
pouilly-en-auxois dans un village où les
aujourd'hui ils sont 70 réfugiés parce
qu'elle est venue là bas pour
stigmatiser la xénophobie qu'elle
développerait tout a commencé à brice
époque heureuse un an plus tôt le débat
car je propose d'abord d'écouter une
réaction de l la candidate marie un
guide du fait tête de liste je vous le
rappelle pour le parti socialiste et qui
selon nos estimations a rassemblé 22
pour l'instant 1,8 pour cent des
suffrages d'écouté marie-guite dufay et
besançon a bien voté j'en suis contente
ce n'est qu'un résultats très partiels
mais besançon et est fidèle à sa
réputation de belleville de gauche même
si
la progression du front national est
quand même très très inquiétante parce
que c'est quand même inédit
voilà un petit mot est là vous suivez
réaliser cette soirée sur les réseaux
sociaux est ce qu'il ya déjà des
réactions justement sur ces estime
beaucoup de réactions justement par
rapport à cette poussée du front
national et à ce score de 32 % en
bourgogne franche comté ce message
d'abord celui de nicolas mais ce jouet
qui est secrétaire de section ps de buxy
ce soir j'ai le sentiment de sentir le
souffle de la bête immonde sur ma nuque
la république est en danger
autre message d'une élue de belfort
adjointe au maire socialiste jacqueline
guiot belfort la peste brune gagne du
terrain
autre message de safia otokoré vice
président dissidente de la région
bourgogne ce soir il me faudra beaucoup
de bourgogne le vin pour ne pas déprimer
et enfin cette question de fadila
khattabi pardonnez-moi incontestablement
après des années de vie politique
bipolaire c'est désormais un échiquier
politique tripolaire à qui la faute de
mon hôtel
merci beaucoup et on repart on part du
côté de besançon rejoindre catherine et
marie catherine amérique qui est avec
deux invités avec un représentant
d'europe écologie les verts est aussi un
représentant pour alternative à gauche
oui bonsoir à tous
ici à besançon donc eric alauzet qui est
député europe ecologie les verts de la
deuxième circonscription du doubs et
puis face à lui christophe lime qui est
membre du parti communiste français et
qui est également adjoint à besançon on
va vous faire réagir d'abord eric
alauzet quels premiers enseignements que
vous tirez de ces résultats qui sont
pour le moment des estimations une
amplification de ce que les sondages
avait annoncé je me pose la question
depuis ce matin à qui va profiter la
mobilisation supplémentaire à midi on
avait des chiffres déjà qu'il ne disait
que les français se déplacer un peu plus
que de 10 visiblement et effectivement
c'est pour le front national
on avait vu dans ces derniers jours que
les événements et l'actualité avait
bénéficié pour 3 4 points au fonds
national pour un point au parti
socialiste ça s'est confirmé aujourd'hui
ça s'est même amplifiée voilà il est
donc on est vraiment dans une situation
tripartite des trois parties et tous les
autres disparaissent
je crois bien que
faut remonter à très longtemps pour voir
l'ensemble des scores liés europe
ecologie les verts au vert à au parti
communiste enfin tous les partis dits
alternative au ps ne pas recueillir à
eux tous ensemble 10% alors actuellement
d'après des estimations donc votre
candidat de cécile prud'hommes n'a pas
le droit de fusionner avec la liste
socialiste de marie-guite dufay
vous vous étiez un des tenants de cette
liste autonome au premier tour
visiblement c'est une erreur de
stratégie non c'est pas ce n'est pas une
erreur de stratégie
ç'a toujours été comme ça aux élections
à deux tours les écologistes se présente
souvent au premier tour je dis souvent à
mes amis ce qui compte c'est l'état
d'esprit si on va au premier tour en
présentant son projet politique
complémentaire alternatif à celui des
autres forces de gauche c'est pas grave
avec l'objectif de gagner ensemble
deuxième tour et donc au 2nd tour les
choses il ya six ans à l'afp cet échec
avait fait investir si vous voulez faire
dire que c'est un échec c'est à sète un
échec absolument ça c'est évident fait
deux fois moins de voix mais ce qui
compte maintenant c'est la victoire de
la gauche au second tour
et dans ce cadre là et bien europe
ecologie les verts apportera tout son
soutien à la liste de marie guite dufay
ça veut dire que déjà officiellement ce
soir vous vous dites c'est tout le monde
sur marie glisser ma position à titre
habituel jus pas eu le temps d'en
discuter encore avec avec mes amis les
doubiens pour moi c'est une évidence
trahi je pense qu'il y aura aucun aucun
état d'âme
surtout parce que front national ait été
levée oui tu en as toujours fait à lyon
ce second tour avec les socialistes
christophe lime pour le parti communiste
français donc je disais vous êtes
adjoint à besançon premier enseignement
comme eric alauzet le front national
très très haut que je pense qu'il ya il
ya deux semaines mais moi je voudrais
quand même pour rien qu'on a toujours un
électeur sur deux qui se déplacent pas
moi j'ai commencé à avoir quelques
résultats sur besançon quand on voit que
sur planoise 30% de participation
je tire la sonnette d'alarmé par rapport
à ça aux gens qu'ils connaissent pas
plein à plein des sept quartiers dits
sensibles de la ville de besançon plus
de vingt mille habitants
je pense que la première des échecs
qu'on peut avoir par rapport à ça c'est
ce taux d'abstention y compris d'un
certain nombre de nos électeurs qui
conteste fortement la politique
d'austérité aujourd'hui mais qui
aujourd'hui ne se déplace pas à
l'intérieur du vôtre c'est un vrai
problème y compris qu'on fera qu'on
analyse nous pour voir comment on arrive
pas à recueillir ce mécontentement oui
vous dépassez pas non plus la barre des
5% prétend qu'il faut quand même
attendre la fin de soirée pour voir
exactement et le qualifie au deuxième
tour ce serait très juste oui mais entre
4,7 et 1,5 savez bien que la commission
sont pas tout à fait les mêmes
y compris ne serait ce que pour voir un
visage et une fusion avec une liste qui
fait plus de 10%
le deuxième point on est quand même sur
une dynamique malheureuse des événements
j'ai aujourd'hui on a bien vu que ces
élections elles n'ont absolument pas
porté sur le terrain économique
absolument pas porté sur tous les
terrains y compris qui pourrait avoir de
la compétence de la région mais
essentiellement sur les problématiques
de sécurité je prends un exemple le la
montée du chômage à quelques jours trois
lignes dans l'ensemble des médias avec
tout ce que cela peut comporter
lendemain complètement oublié pour des
raisons diverses l'idée ce n'est pas de
culpabiliser qui que ce soit nous on
voit bien que cette élection a été
marquée sous l'émotion qui a tout
particulièrement profité au front
national là je suis d'accord avec eric
alauzet on était dans une dynamique
qu'on a bien vu malheureuse depuis
quelques jours du montée du front
national et qui se concrétise
aujourd'hui
enfin je vous rendrai sur une surprise
mais le front national arrive en tête en
franche comté
c'est déjà arrivé à multiples élections
ce que je suis en train de vous poser la
question de l'analyser on avait bien vu
le front national a pris 6% dans les
quinze derniers jours
et là il est encore un ou deux pourcent
par rapport au dernier sondage
on voit bien qu'il ya une dynamique par
rapport à ça un repli c'est bien un
repli identitaire par rapport à certain
nombre d'éléments et tous les discours
qu'ont pu être tenues aujourd'hui n'ont
fait que leur c'est ce que nous sommes
ce conflit bien qu'alors l'a qualifié ou
pas a priori vous l'êtes pas est ce que
vous appelez quand même à voter pour
marie guite dufay dès ce soir
alors déjà notre liste vous avez
remarqué que
rassemblement de différentes listes et
on respectera l'ensemble des éléments
qui sont à l'intérieur des formations
politiques voire des non encartés la
terre de ses fils et notre notre volonté
donc ce soir l'ensemble des candidats
vont être réunis dans l'est dans les
prochaines minutes à sur l'ensemble des
départements
il y aura une analyse d'uriné résine pas
que vous ne publiez pas à bt marie-guite
dufay contenu du béryl front national 8
mai sauf que quand on fait une liste on
respecte ses partenaires et donc à
partir de là je ne suis pas habilité ce
soir donné un certain nombre de
positions parce que si demain on veut
construire le front de gauche on veut
construire le flambeau l'élargir sur un
certain nombre de choses on n'avancera
pas si on se respecte pas oui vous à
titre personnel et ce sera le mot de la
fin avec vous que les mois je n'ai pas
de titre personnel à voir sur un certain
nombre de choses j'ai un certain nombre
d'éléments à prendre et moi le titre
personnel c'est le respect de mes
partenaires
très bien merci à tout à l'heure pour de
nouveaux invités
merci de tout à leur direction paiement
haute saône la parole aux électeurs
également peine commune limitrophe avec
le jura et la côte d'or c'est pour ça
que nous avons voulu nous installer ce
soir également avec vous ou vanessa
hirson oui effectivement on est tous
jours après mais je suis avec dominique
qui travaillent la communauté de
communes du val de peine et vous êtes
bourguillon votre femme franc comtoise
comment elle semblait cet événement chez
vous on le vit très sereinement puisque
ça fait maintenant 14 ans qu'on habite m
et ce village il a la particularité de
se trouver au carrefour de quatre
départements et donc nos habitudes de
vie nous amène aussi bien aller dans le
jura qu en côte d'or
alors justement quand est ce que vous
êtes dangereux quand est ce que vous
allez encore là ça va être
toujours pour la même chose
essentiellement plus rugby puisque mon
fils noam joue à lui s dole et puis moi
même je joue encore au bout de dix ans
vétérans avec mes amis des arts de cases
d'auxonne
voilà donc vous êtes déjà bourguignon
par la proximité avec la we can oui tout
à fait je suis bon je suis franc comtois
d'adoption je reste bourrignon coeur
évidemment puisque mes enfants sont nés
tous les deux à besançon et donc ils ont
toujours vécu à peine est ce que vous
faites à l'idée que vous allez aussi
être franc comtois je me fais oui je
suis franc comtois je peux dire je suis
franc comtois d'adoption et puis et
rencontra d'adoption puis bourguignon
coeur c'est bien parce que ça permet aux
francs comtois de découvrir plein de
choses chez nous d'accord du coup
pourrait bien compris dominique est
aussi un franc comtois et c'est un
habitué en fait des deux régions voilà
merci vanessa 20h40 sur france 3 soirée
spéciale élections régionales avec un
rappel de l'estimation que nous vous
donnions tout à l'heure concernant cette
grande région
oui on refait le point sur les
estimations avec d'abord je vous
rappelle que le front national est en
tête avec 32,1 pour cent des suffrages
derrière la liste de françois sauvadet
leur rugby 23 5%
marie-guite dufay arrivons troisième ps
prg 22,8 pour cent il y a maxime
thiébaut pour debout la france qui
serait autour des 5% nathalie vermorel
pour le front de gauche alternative à
gauche 4,7 pour cent christophe grudler
pour le modem 3,4 pour cent avec cécile
prud'hommes pour europe ecologie les
verts 4 % enfin nous avons julien
gonzalez pour elle a eu ici à 2,2 pour
cent à claire rocher pour lutte ouvrière
1 4%
enfin charles henri gallois pour l'upm
0,9 pour cent on revient sur le plateau
juste une précision peut-être sur la
règle électorale on vous parle de la
barre symbolique des 50 ou le sang
depuis tout à l'heure parce que sont
qualifiés ce soir pour le deuxième tour
directement les trois premières listes
puisque elles franchissent tout et même
largement la barre des 10% c'est la
règle pour se qualifier pour le second
tour
directement et la barre des 5% c'est la
barre qui permet de fusionner entre les
deux tours avec l'une des principales
listes c'est une barre symbolique et on
voit qu'il ya plusieurs listes là on est
dans la marge d'erreur est du coup
notamment pour maxime thiébaut est
debout la france il est estimé à 5 à 20
heures il peut être à 5,1 ou à 4,9 et
être en état de fusionner ou pas et du
coup je me tourne vers arnaud danjean
edouard ferrand c'est un peu un
positionnement particulier debout la
france c'est nicolas dupont aignan c'est
une droite patriote on va dire est ce
que l'un ou l'autre du mais pendant les
mois mais je récuse ce terme de
patriotes est ce que moi je suis pas
patriote c'est eux qui seraient non mais
qui se faisait rien donné cela à temps
des souverainistes si vous découvrez si
vous l'aimez patriotes ans je fais une
consistance je sais que mon voisin de
gauche ce soir adore ce terme et enfin
moi je sursaute à chaque fois que
j'entends qu'on se qualifie sur
l'échiquier politique de patriotes ou
pas est-ce que françois patriat n'est
pas patriote est ce que moi je suis pas
patriote avec les médiateurs jovial ou
répondu à ma question et me dire si
aujourd'hui vous envisagez de discuter
avec maxime tvo mais on discute de toute
façon avec maxime thiébaut
on a fait ça fait vraiment qu'on discute
avec maxime thibon on verra les
résultats comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même il faut affiner on va voir
tout ça on va voir les ventilations
aussi départementales qui sont
importantes parce que ça va peser dans
la balance de ce qui se passera dans
l'entre-deux tours donc on verra on va
on va parler de toute façon qui soit au
dessus de 5 ou en dessous de 5 il faudra
bien discuté avec lui et on savoir ce
secteur a priori de fusion avec de
gaulle air france alors nous nous avons
indiqué depuis longtemps que nous
souhaitions conserver une cohérence à
notre liste et à notre programme
françois sauvadet a dit très clairement
on ne change pas de ligne on change pas
de programme on change pas l'équipe on
va voir on va se réunir demain matin on
va voir tout ça à tête reposée avec
l'ensemble des résultats affinés et
définitif dont nous disposons c'est pas
encore le cas pour debout la france moi
je connais bien maxime t mobile et en
saône et loire
je sais très bien que les gens qui
votent debout la france et s'ils avaient
voulu voter un petit peu plus décalé il
serait déjà allé au front national au
premier tour donc je ne crois pas que ce
soit des gens qui ont vocation à aller
au front national
quand bien même sur certains thèmes on
pourrait penser optiquement qu'il ya des
rapprochements
moi je pense que c'est des gens qui
restent dans des familles républicaines
et qui sont attachés à ce socle commun
et qui sont sur un vote régional
attachés à des idées programmatique et
je ne vois pas de différence
fondamentale avec maxime thibeault sur
ce qui est la gestion d'une région et
c'est quand même ce qui va apporter
aussi entre les deux tours sur l'europe
sur l'europe bien évidemment y mais la
différence de taille il enfin l'europe
la région savez la région va gérer les
fonds européens ça c'est une chose mais
ça demande pas un théâtre la sapo sa
demande pas un positionnement
souverainiste pas souverainiste les
fonds européens ils sont attribués aux
régions quoi qu'il advienne quel que
soit votre coloration politique comme le
front national a à faire avec la gestion
des fonds européens
edouard ferrand chela tête pendant que
vous disiez s'ils avaient voulu voter
front national il l'aurait déjà fait moi
je pense je pense que pour françois
sauvadet c'est l'élection de trop je
crois que françois sauvadet est un super
cumulard qu' il veut tu as la tête de
tous finalement il va être être à la
tête de rien et régional européen
régionale sortante m'exprimer parce que
pour l'instant la parole a été donnée à
mes adversaires je dois simplement dire
qu'aujourd'hui la montée de debout la
france c'est surtout l'échec de ce
modèle parce que c'est des voix qui
naturellement aurait dû aller vers l'est
républicain mais comme les répliquer en
tout rogner iso rogner leur position sur
l'europe se renier leurs positions sur
la famille ils ont remis également à
leurs positions économiques
les français voient bien qu'aujourd'hui
ils vivent dans la souffrance que les
difficultés de vie les difficultés de
croissance les difficultés de pouvoir
d'achat
et bien c'est aussi la conséquence non
pas d'eau pas uniquement de hollande
mais aussi de sarkozy donc les patriotes
et le souverainiste qui sont autour de
debout la france s'ils franchissent les
5%
ils iront tout naturellement vers le
front national parce que c'est les seuls
avec lesquelles ce sont nos cousins
germains et je pense que ce sont les
seuls avec lesquels ils peuvent avoir
une affinité politique et surtout un
développement politique durable ici en
bourgogne et en franche comté
je crois que la droite n'a pas de
réserve de voix qu'aujourd'hui l'ump
enfin les républicains sont dans une
situation extrêmement difficile s'il n'y
aura pas de dynamique de second tour et
je crois qu'à dynamique et soit plutôt
du côté de la gauche parce qu'ils ont un
peu plus de 1 certes deux fois
ne cachons pas les yeux je crois
qu'aujourd'hui debout la france et tous
les patriotes qui aujourd'hui se soit
abstenue pour voir naître un trio qui
rétais c'est aussi peut accélérer je
vous ai bien je pense qu'on aurait
demain la dynamique elle est au tour de
sophie montel un mot pour dire que ça
jamais été aussi serrée depuis le
changement de mode de scrutin on se
retrouve presque dans la situation
d'avant changement de mode de scrutin où
tout pourrait se jouer à 1,6 à une voix
lors de l'élection du président on sait
pas très bien mais dans ce scrutin
d'abord c'est la première fois qu'on se
retrouve avec trois blocs avant il y
avait bipartisme et le frein sur la côte
est deuxième chose cette élection a lieu
dans un contexte dramatique d'état
d'urgence qui a profité pour marquer
tout à l'heure on l'a dit on l'a dit m
moi je regarde mon temps je me dis nous
faisons a réuni un résultat mieux que
prévu par les sondages avec nettement
mieux prévu ont donné à marie du fai va
t elle est à 23,8 dire une vraie
progression une vraie mobilisation
donc ça veut dire qu'elle à mobiliser
son camp maintenant il nous faut
mobiliser la gauche
moi j'ai un regret c'est qu'on ne sommes
pas allés serions pas allés ensemble
comme je l'avais fait en 2004
en 2010 ce qu'on aurait ce soir un autre
chiffre qui qui aurait montrèrent
montrerait notre dynamique mais ils
restent verts qui pour l'instant n'est
ce pas le seuil des 5 ça veut dire que
le reste mais vous avez vu quand même
que j'ai cru comprendre que du côté
d'europe écologie les verts
le thé disposé à jouer le jeu de la
gauche je pense que wild rose et de
toute façon il va tout toutes les
propositions du gouvernement a même plus
que certains socialistes la gauche la
gauche a des réserves qui peuvent lui
permettre d'envisager la victoire et
c'est là dessus que moi j'appelle
vraiment ce soir si j'ai un message à
passer c'est sérieux rassemblement parce
que tout ce dont nous ne voulons pas
c'est demain la bourgogne franche comté
gouverné par le front national
quoi qu'il faudra fêter ça ce soir et
dire que c'est possible si on se
mobilise direction belfort on part à
belfort effectivement retrouvé damien
meslot député maire de la ville
bonsoir monsieur mêle soul réactions
déjà bon soir on va écouter
il ya une forte poussée du front
national la liste de françois sauvadet
arrive en deuxième position
donc il faut que tous les démocrates et
les républicains se regroupe derrière la
liste arrivée en deuxième position pour
arriver à barrer la route au front
national
j'invite tous les électeurs qui ont voté
pour le modem tous ceux qui ont voté
pour debout la france à nous rejoindre
et à constituer une majorité pour battre
le front national
damien meslot la liste du parti
socialiste est très proche de la liste
de françois sauvadet
on s'attendait à un écart plus grand
j'imagine que vous l'espériez est ce que
la dynamique est pas plutôt du côté de
la gauche et du front national est
absolument pas de votre côté
alors il faut vraiment être un
journaliste compliqué pour penser que la
liste qui arrivait en troisième position
bénéficie d'une plus grande dynamique
que la liste qui arrivait en deuxième
position il ya des réserves de joie plus
évidente simple écoute et on verra bien
mais je ne suis pas sûr que les gens qui
ont voté pour le front de gauche pour
sanctionner la politique libérale de
macron ait envie de voter pour madame du
fait donc ça c'est votre analyse
moi je pense que les électeurs qui ont
voté modem ou qui ont voté debout la
france vont beaucoup plus naturellement
aller vers l'est républicain que les
électeurs du front de gauche verts le
parti socialiste donc maintenant le
premier tour s'est passé nous sommes
dans une logique de deuxième tour nous
allons regarder si il y à possibilité de
fusionner avec d'autres listes mais
d'ores et déjà nous allons nous réunir
ce soir et demain matin pour enclencher
une deuxième partie de la compagne et
moi je pense que françois sauvadet est
très bien placé pour gagner la région et
barrer la route au front national damien
meslot merci indirecte de belfort le
modem à présent nous prenons la
direction de mâcon en préfecture sophie
nicolet nous attend pour le modem est
donné à 3 4% dans notre estimation donc
pas de fusion possible avec une autre
liste
quelle sera la consigne
donnée par le modem pour ce deuxième
tour sophie nicolet je pourrais pas vous
donner la consigne que donnera le modem
puisque puisque je vais surtout vous
parlez du département mais qu'en tout
cas j'espère que j'entends parler les
personnes sur le présent sur le plateau
la s'invectiver je suis assez déçu parce
que très honnêtement quand on voit le
résultat du front national j'espère
qu'ils arriveront à se mettre d'accord
parce que là en tout état de cause on
risque d'avoir des soucis et j'en
profite pour rappeler toute la jeunesse
de france et surtout de bourgogne
franche comté à se mobiliser pour le
2ème tour parce que je pense qu'ils ont
été relativement absents dans cette
élection comme il l'avait dit dans les
précédentes et c'est à eux de faire
changer les choses
3 4% c'est une déception tout de même
pour la bourgogne franche comté pour le
modem bien sûr bien sûr c'est une
déception c'est le choix des électeurs
donc on va pas veut pas le renier après
le contexte n'a pas été favorable pour
nous évidemment et parce que parce qu'il
ya eu des drames si terrible que toutes
les campagnes ont été arrêtés évidemment
et que
les gens avaient la tête à autre chose
et malheureusement malheureusement à
cause de ce contexte si particulier je
crois que les français se sont trompés
et particulièrement en bourgogne franche
comté mais met aussi en nord pas de
calais en paca les français se sont
trompés d'élection on parle on parle pas
du tout deux régions à peine en parlant
de la dette et finalement on se trompe
j'entendais à madame montel dire dire
des mensonges tout à l'heure ça me fait
peur ça me fait peur parce que
finalement on n'a pas voté pour les
bonnes choses et là aujourd'hui on parle
de formation continue on parle d'emploi
on parle de lycée on parle de culture et
tout ça finalement c'est totalement
oublié des discours qu'on peut entendre
aujourd'hui son plateau une question de
positionnement alors peut-être un petit
peu triviale mais on sait christophe
grudler à regarder longtemps du côté de
françois sauvadet on sait aussi qu'il a
discuté avec les vice présidents
socialistes dissidente du conseil
régional de bourgogne
est ce que le modem a pas souffert d'un
positionnement un petit peu floue dans
cette élection finalement entre ces ses
allers retours entre différents
partenaires possibles non je pense pas
je pense que vous savez aujourd'hui les
gens ils l'ont bien montré d'ailleurs en
votant si massivement fn et si peu
finalement pour les partis traditionnels
que je n'appellerai unis de gouvernement
ni républicain parce que je pense que
c'est un terme aujourd'hui totalement
fourvoyé
aujourd'hui les gens veulent autre chose
la question est simplement là de savoir
qu'on est capable de travailler avec la
droite avec la gauche pense que les gens
le savent
les centristes sont en mesure de
construire et d'avancer donc ça c'est
pas ce n'est pas tant le débat
je pense qu'aujourd'hui simplement le
ski s'est manifesté c'est le fait de
vouloir essayer autre chose une autre
manière de faire de la politique une
autre manière de consulter les gens et
ça on va y réfléchir évidemment il faut
qu'on qu'on sache répondre aux attentes
et aux besoins des citoyens
sophie niccolo nalio préfecture de mâcon
merci à vous nous évoquerons à nouveau
et surtout les résultats de chaque liste
tout au long de cette soirée sur france
retrouvez les résultats également sur
notre site internet une commune nous a
également intéressé celle de jergens
centre géographique de la future
bourgogne franche comté et dans cette
commune dans ce village le front
national est arrivé en tête là aussi les
électeurs se sont plus déplacés que dans
la moyenne avec 67% de participation
définitive dans ce village regarder au
centre de la région et des attentions
le petit village de jergens 120
habitants centre géographique s'est
ainsi senti plus mobilisés avec plus de
60 % de participation
et dans les yeux c'est le front national
qui arrive largement en tête 35% des
voix loin devant la droite et la gauche
qui en additionnant leurs deux corps
dépasse darien le parti frontiste déçu
non surpris un peu quand même mais c'est
vrai que l'on sent bien qu'il ya quand
même un certain désamour du politiques
rivaux de des électeurs fois compte tenu
des événements dernier est bien évident
que ça renforcer une montée de l'autre
partie donc ça c'était quelque chose que
j'avais plus ou moins pressenti on
ressent quand même ce malaise
bien qu'on soit dans une petite bourgade
une petite commune où on n'est pas
vraiment touché par par tout ça gergoy
il n'avait jamais connu un tel vote
front national si marine le pen était
arrivé en tête d'une seule voix lors de
la dernière présidentielle
ici on vote d'habitude plutôt à droite
c'est bien nouveau pour nous il ya un
grand changement et puis là on verra
bien
bah je pense que les gens sont
extrêmement déçu et c'est là une façon
de s'exprimer
le centre de la région est donc passé à
l'extrême droite
tout un symbole avant de redonner à la
parole à nos invités en plateau elsa un
tweet de maxime thibeault oui on
guettait depuis tout à l'heure si il
allait réagir et bien il affirme je vais
vous le montrer il félicite son équipe
il affirme que son score est supérieur à
5%
il affirme que c'est la victoire de
l'alternative à savoir un vrai programme
régional et du terrain il ne donne
aucune consigne de vote par contre
l'humiliant jérémy anglès l'appareil de
parler de jergens zones rurales on s'est
posé la question aussi du vote
en franche comté et parce que il ya dans
par exemple la montée du vote front
national aussi quelque chose autour de
la fusion des régions et de cette grande
région de dande en soit les poser la
question d'argent d'abord et puis
ensuite je répondrai tout d'abord sont
ici parce que ce faire on me l'a dit à
l'oreille il après ils n'ont pas été les
seuls à s'opposer à la fusion nous y
étions également opposés mais dès lors
qu'elle a été actée par la loi vous
opposez pas à la loi une fois qu'elle
est votée c'est ça on est républicain et
on n'est pas bon vous avez voté la loi
d'autres vous vous êtes à l'assemblée
nationale non mais attendez vous êtes à
l'assemblée c'est lol moi non plus
arrêtez de dire n'importe quoi
écoutez vous n'êtes même pas candidat
alors vous êtes gentil mais je suis et
je vous êtes vous êtes aussi 0 db tête
vous étaient ceux des adultes européens
un touriste politique même ça vous êtes
gentil mais moi j'aime candidat il se
trouve que wafa monsieur monsieur pour
tous
quand jean ne pratique que l'invectivé
n'a plus d'argument aujourd'hui sa liste
vous casser la gueule mais néanmoins
suis à vous que j'ai donné la parole
maintenant voix doit refaire ce n'est
pas parce que je suis la fille d'andré
par la cei s'est foulé aux pieds tu
exprimes antennes et moi je me
laisserais aussi insulté mais non moi je
pense qu'aujourd'hui vous le laisser
terminer sa phrase
monsieur dont jean perd ses nerfs parce
qu'il a perdu en politique et vous il va
vraiment d'abord je perds pas mes nerfs
je fais une analyse politique qu'on me
demande je suis sollicité j'aurais pas
une question d'argent mais moi je
réponds je réponds aux questions
la zone les zones rurales moi je suis
issue d'une zone rurale vote
effectivement assez massivement front
national c'est un fait mais on peut
répondre et musique et moi je fais pas
d'invectivés moi j'ai la réponse de la
dose de caniveau mais par rapport à la
question précise qui m'a été posée sur
la fusion
ça participe de l'éloignement du centre
de décision par rapport aux citoyens ça
a été la même chose avec les redécoupage
des cantons et c'est fusion avec un mode
de scrutin binominal incompréhensible
c'est la même chose avec les régions où
on fusionne les régions c'est la même
chose en ce même en ce moment sur les
communautés de communes tous les
territoires ruraux sont agités par des
débats très important sur la les
regroupements de communes tout ça
participe d'un seul mouvement éloigner
le centre des six décisions des citoyens
et par rapport à ça pas les citoyens
disent
pardonnez moi vous nous embêter nous
enquiquiner on aimerait bien savoir pour
qui on vote on aimerait bien avoir des
élus plus proche
je note aussi ça se confirmera sans
doute quand on regarde quand on regarde
la liste quant aux rosaires pro européen
mais ça veut rien dire ce que vous dites
les aveux on va le maire de la ville le
maire socialiste jean louis fousseret et
cielo à besançon bon je crois le
résultat pour votre ville de besançon
pour ce premier tour sans voix qui
serait un jour non sait pas encore si
c'est à vous oui bonjour les résultats
est tombé pour la religion juive écoutez
je vous écoute
oui le résultat est tombé pour la vie de
mes chansons besançon résiste bien la
participation au niveau national est
équivalente à celle de besançon
besançon résiste bien puisque
marie-guite dufay fait presque 35% au
premier tour soit 15 points de plus que
françois sauvadet le front national
étant en deuxième
position donc cela montre aussi que les
bisontines les bisontins ont compris que
les dr ces derniers mois marie glee fait
moi même avons défendu au niveau
national les intérêts de besançon et
qu'il qu'ils nous font confiance et cela
aussi confirme la qualité du travail de
marie-guite dufay
pendant toutes ces années marie du fait
s'est elle refuse le bling-bling les
flonflons
c'est quelqu'un qui travaille qui
travaille pour la région pour le
développement économique pour la
formation pour améliorer la qualité de
vie si en franche-comté je crois que
c'est une juste reconnaissance
je suis surpris cependant de
l'effondrement de la droite locale le
puisque désormais c'est le front
national qui est en seconde position je
suis surpris et j'appelle surtout pour
dimanche prochain un grand sursaut
sursaut de toutes les forces de gauche
et de progrès pour gagner cette région
et là on se rend compte aussi que
lorsque nous ne sommes pas unis à gauche
nous pouvons prendre et si nous pouvons
perdre des municipales nous étions unis
ensemble nous avons gagné dans un
contexte difficile nous avons
effectivement gagné là le contexte est
difficile et même très difficile donc il
faut absolument que dimanche prochain
effectivement toutes les forces de
gauche et forces de progrès il soit là
rassemblés pour faire gagner marie-guite
dufay gens les fossés que pour cette
région puissent continuer à se
développer comme elle l'a fait depuis
tant d'années merci enregistré en direct
de besançon maire socialiste de la ville
nous rappelons merci à vous nous allons
revoir tous les résultats tout à l'heure
bien évidemment pour cette estimation
cette première estimation donnée depuis
20h15 et sur internet vous retrouver
bien sûr tout au long de cette soirée
les résultats de votre département que
tu les arriveront au fur et à mesure de
la soirée ou d'un oui et pour ça on à
sophie courageot clés du côté de
besançon keynote pilote web sophie
qu'est-ce qui est déjà en ligne
j'imagine beaucoup de choses déjà pour
les internautes qui le souhaitent
je ne suis pas de jeux d'affilée
c'est un mode le direct minute par
minute un fil info les résultats on
commençait à tomber commune par commune
si vous voulez jeter un oeil et puis
nous mettrons en ligne dès que nous les
aurons les premières réactions des
candidats sur le terrain et puis on
attend comme vous bien les résultats
définitifs deux adresses france 3 pour 1
fr direction la bourgogne ou direction
la franche-comté ya tout à l'heure merci
beaucoup bon courage pour la suite ce
film a rappelé rapidement elle est bien
arnaud que le front national arrive
selon les premières estimations en tête
pour ce premier tour avec un score
autour de 32 % pour la liste conduite
par sophie montel devant vous le voyez
françois sauvadet la liste elle est rude
et y a un peu plus de 23%
près de 23 pour la liste socialiste
incertitude pour la liste debout la
france autour des 5% estimations que
nous affinerons tout au long de la
soirée qu'il se poursuit avec et francis
letellier et carole gaessler à tout à
l'heure dans un quart d'heure